ce présent jeu non ce qu'à compter du
1er septembre 2014 de tarifs pour les
services de garde parce qu'à 8 dollars
par jour puis à 9 $ l'année suivante et
qui sera ensuite indexé pour les années
subséquentes
alors c'était un des faits saillants
diar évidemment cette hausse annoncée
pour les tarifs de services de garde
une hausse qui reçoit un accueil plutôt
froid vous allez voir de la part des cpe
espère une augmentation mais juge que
celle proposée par québec est trop
brutale david gêne-t-il edel rejoindra
bientôt trois autres frères et soeurs en
cp pour sa mère la hausse de tarif est
synonyme de sacrifices et les camps
d'été pied les cours de les cours de
gymnastique les cours de danse les cours
de musique
c'est là que je vais couper epinal un
sénégal l'association québécoise des cpe
souhaitait une hausse mais
l'augmentation proposée serait trop
brutale environ 500 $ par enfant par
année 500 $ par enfant si on en outre
aux quatre services de garde c'est
vraiment une hausse importante et ceci
dès la première année
une hausse qui touche aussi les services
de garde en milieu scolaire la ministre
promet que les millions encaissés
resteront dans le réseau des cpe
cet argent-là materi investi parce que
vous savez ces 28e place qu'on étant
contraint de faire en santé on veut
limiter la hausse des budgets à 3% cette
année
mais ça ne suffira pas à compenser
l'augmentation réelle des coûts ces 400
millions de moins que ce qu'on a besoin
les établissements de santé pour
continuer à offrir les services actuels
à la population
donc on peut penser une baisse de
service le gouvernement songe plutôt à
demander la collaboration des médecins
il va falloir quand même s'asseoir avec
les docteurs parce que il ya 100 540
millions d'augmentation de salaire
des médecins des augmentations qui
accapare plus de la moitié des hausses
des dépenses dans le réseau de la santé
cette année
québec n'a pas le choix et doit
présenter un bon bilan financier entre
autres pour rassurer les agences de
notation qui pour l'instant ont décidé
de maintenir la cote de crédit du québec
ici david gêne-t-il et radio canada
québec